salut les épis curieuse et les épis
curieux je suis ravi de vous accueillir
dans mon atelier pour un nouveau format
qui a vu le jour au début de l'été et
qui plus que jamais consacrée à l'
échange la connaissance est aussi l
aventure dans bien reçue c'est le nom de
ce format j'ouvre cet espace à des
personnalités connues ou pas pour
partager avec elles leur expérience leur
passion leur curiosité leur goût du
savoir et aussi leurs projets des femmes
et des hommes jeunes ou moins jeunes qui
ont toutes et tous une belle histoire à
nous raconter un message à nous faire
passer aujourd'hui bien reçu l'atelier
se transforme en quarts et nous mettons
les voir le cap sur les mers du sud je
suis très heureux d'accueillir l'anah le
nourrit et niels dutrievoz deux
étudiants membres de l'expédition
antarctique ne devient
jamais installez-vous
le grand public ne vous connais pas je
vais donc vous présenter la nse vous
avez tous les 24 ans vous êtes étudiant
à l'école normale supérieure de paris
saclay vous êtes de futurs chercheurs et
vous vous apprêtez à embarquer à bord de
la louise goélette de 19 m et à bord de
laquelle vous allez rejoindre la
péninsule antarctique
vous serez six étudiants à bord deux
étudiantes quatre étudiants et vous
étudiez tous dans des disciplines
différentes
l'anah c'est quoi ta discipline alors
moi j'ai travaillé sur
la biologie des populations de manchots
en antarctique
moi je vais étudier la climatologie et
la glaciologie alors avec vous il y aura
également marc mollo galles qui elle est
étudiante en sociologie vous me dites
ainsi je dis des bêtises il y aura
baptiste arnaud lui c'est la
microbiologie clément astruc de l'or la
biogéochimie et olivier smith la chimie
c'est sa chimie des micro plastiques
exactement chimie des micro plastiques
sans faute presque vous prenez quelque
chose un petit café un thé moi je
partirai rien 5 un film parfait deux
cafés alors vous avez vu tout autour de
nous il ya pas mal de mugs je vous
invite à choisir le vôtre il y en a une
centaine peut-être que vous trouverez
une thématique qui vous convient voilà
la ba oui c'est évident pour moi c'est
assez vite vu le manchot pour l'anah et
moi je vais choisir
celui ci
avec le vent
et oui puisqu'on va parler de
météorologie et de climatologie et de
rivières atmosphérique alors quel est
l'objectif de cette expédition alors
notre objectif c'est de nous rendent en
antarctique pour ça on va partir à bord
d'un voilier locle à louise que tu as
présenté pendant six mois on part de
france traverse l'atlantique et
l'objectif en antarctique et pendant la
traversée de l'océan c'est d'étudier
l'impact de l'homme sur l'environnement
donc que ce soit la pollution ou le
climat ok alors on va avoir l'occasion
de revenir sur sur tout ça juste un mot
sur le déroulement donc de cet échange
quand vous avez pu le remarquer cet
atelier c'est un petit peu la caverne
d'ali baba la petite caméra et moi on y
stocke tout un tas d'objets qu'on a
glanées ici ou là et on en a sélectionné
certains qu'on a disséminé dans cette
pièce qui correspondent aux différentes
thématiques et à ce que vous allez vivre
durant durant cette aventure donc ce que
je vous propose est bien c'est chacun à
votre tour d'aller chercher un objet qui
évoque votre expédition l'anah je
t'invite à les faire le premier
prélèvement dans cet atelier voilà alors
moi je veux bien commencer par le bateau
voilà alors ce bateau celui ci c'est une
maquette c'est pas exactement celui que
vous allez à bord duquel vous aller
naviguer il ressemble malgré tout parce
que c'est une grosse tête et vous aller
naviguer sur une galette la louise un
bateau de 19 mètres qui est appareillé
pour aller dans des eaux des eaux
polaires exactement est en fait
l'histoire de ce bateau c'est que c'est
le capitaine donc thierry dubois qui l'a
construit c'est pas n'importe qui
thierry du moins c'est un marin
chevronné il a été vainqueur de la mini
transat en 1993 il a fait
le vendée globe deux fois et une fois
d'ailleurs où il a chaviré il a vécu
pendant des heures très difficiles donc
il connaît un petit peu les eaux dans
lesquels vous allez nabiye icônes et les
eaux il a l'habitude de naviguer
l'équipage avec lequel on part est un
équipage qu'il connaît bien s'il a
l'habitude de naviguer avec eux donc je
pense qu'on sera relativement bien
entouré pour cette expédition voilà où
il y en a qui sont navigateur parmi vous
dans l'équipe alors n'est pas de
navigateur une action un peu
d'expérience en voile mais rien de
comparable à ce qu'on va faire et pour
compléter ce que disait l'anah je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on est tellement la tête
baissée dans les préparations du voyage
qu'on sait pas vraiment projeter encore
sur le temple dans l'expédition et je
pense que je sais pas quand est-ce que
ça va arriver le petit déclic de on part
vraiment peut-être quand on va mettre le
pied dessus qu'on va larguer les amarres
19 mètres à 9 c c'est peu au bout du
compte c'est peu mais le bateau est
relativement bien agencé il ya beaucoup
de cloisons donc en fait ça permettra à
chacun d'avoir pas son espace proprement
parler mais un peu d'intimité par
moments qu'est-ce qu'on emmène quand on
perd pendant six mois et qu'on va vivre
sur un bateau de 19 mètres le nécessaire
surtout que on va voir donc d'une part
va tout nos bagages personnels mais
surtout surtout le matériel scientifique
qui prend quand même pas mal de place et
tous les affaires de froid pour
l'antarctique vous emmener des bouquins
oui vraiment des bouquins plein de
bouquins qu'est-ce que vous emmenez
comme comme bouquin avec vous il ya des
bouquins pour étudier parce qu'on est
quand même dans une année d'étude aussi
de découvrir de travail et
personnellement j'ai pris également des
bouquins qui traite de l'antarctique les
récits de grands explorateurs que ce
soit les aventures de shackleton ou au
niveau de la base de vostok ses dépens
des aventures qui sont incroyables donc
j'ai pris les bouquins pour les lire et
relire pendant le trajet l'anah du coup
moi ça concerne aussi une expédition
c'est celle de charcot qui en fait
retrace exactement le parcours qu'on va
faire l'huile aller un peu plus loin que
nous il a dû hiverner ce que j'espère
qu'ils arrivera pas et je pense que ces
deux mois de transatlantic seront une
occasion rêvée pour enfants lire ce
livre allait un 2e objet nils alors je
vais choisir le globe ça va me permettre
de parler de l'itinéraire vous partez
loup on va partir de france marseille
donc en méditerranée donc traverser la
méditerranée passé gibraltar on va
descendre au niveau des îles canaries
ensuite on va passer au cap vert suite
aura traversé l'atlantique pour
rejoindre le large du brésil on va
descendre le long du brésil de
l'argentine pour arriver à la pointe sud
on va rester pendant deux semaines au
niveau de puntarenas donc au chili et
ensuite on arrive au niveau du nord de
la péninsule on remonte par le même
itinéraire quasiment pour retourner en
bretagne à lorient pourquoi avez vous
choisi cette destination
précisément la péninsule antarctique et
pas un autre point sur ce continent
c'est la seule région en antarctique où
on peut se rendre en bateau qui n'est
pas un brise-glace troisième objet c'est
ce qu'on peut faire un petit point sur
peut-être tout ce qui est pédagogie dans
le projet en quoi ça consiste
précisément la première chose qu'on a
envie de partager c'est bien sûr cette
expédition est aussi peut-être ce goût
pour la science parce que finalement
quand on est jeune on ne sait pas ce que
c'est que le métier de chercheur on
l'apprend tardivement et pourtant on le
fait tous les jours à l'école on fait de
la recherche dans la cour de récré comme
en classe quand vous dites on essaie de
les sensibiliser aux au métier de
chercheur qu'est ce que vous leur dites
vous pour justement leur donner
peut-être envie de faire ce métier ou de
regarder le métier de chercheur avec un
autre un autre regard on veut étudier
par exemple
je ne sais pas pour les plus jeunes et
l'évolution de la température en
fonction de la latitude
on peut donc faire des hypothèses quand
on est dans la classe ensuite on monte
un protocole pour essayer de voir
concrètement comment on peut tester ça
sur le terrain nous sur le bateau ça va
être une expérience qu'on va pouvoir
faire les données leur seront
communiquées suite l'idée c'est
d'interpréter et de conclure sur ses
résultats la méthode scientifique en
quelque sort et m'en allais un autre
objet nils tu as ton tour je vais
prendre la veste vous saurez dans
l'hémisphère sud et que dans
l'hémisphère sud évidemment les saisons
sont inversées et donc quand vous
arriverez en décembre dans dans cette
région et vous serez au début de l'été
austral oui complètement ce sera
décembre janvier février c'est la
période
estivale celle perdue vers dans la
durant laquelle on peut se rendre donc
cliqué moins froid donc il ya moins de
banquise ils pousseront dans
l'antarctique commune et estivale c'est
quand même pas très chaud non plus non
non concurrents température moyenne à
peu près 1 degré ça peut osciller entre
eux du moins 5° et du plus est dans
cette région ça peut descendre à moins
30 à peu près l'hiver ces températures
froides vous y être préparé un petit peu
en fait on s'est entraîné cet hiver
aux arcs ans déjà physiquement mais
aussi à camper dans la neige donc
c'était une forme de préparation un
petit peu aux températures assez froides
qu'on va voir alors en parlant de
conditions météo et d'équipements et à
quelqu'un qui avait un petit message à
vous faire passer venez avec moi alors
je ne vous présente pas ce personnage
pense que vous le connaissez
bonjour la vous et à bientôt route pour
aller en antarctique
j'aimerais bien vous donner d'autres
petit conseil d'abord vous allez sortir
pendant l'été il fait 24 heures sur 24
du soleil et il fait pas vraiment trop
froid quand on reste sur la bordure de
l'antarctique quand on va au milieu
c'est sûr que là il commence à faire
beaucoup plus froid il faut jamais aller
sans lunettes de soleil parce qu'une
fois qu'on a brûlé les yeux les gars
vous voyez plus rien après quand
vous faites des efforts il faut surtout
pas transpiré mettez des couches de
vêtements sous-vêtements den avec du
surcouche qui respire et quand vous êtes
stationnaire pour très longtemps là il
faut mettre en veille en plus la
troisième petit conseil que je vous vous
donner c'est de bien garder du pied au c
est parce qu on transpire un tout petit
peu des chaussées de bien mouillé et là
on commence de gel et les pieds si vous
êtes comme moi pendant une période de
130 jours tous les jours sur la glace et
on a dix chaussée mouillée c'est sûr
qu'on va commencer d'avoir des problèmes
voilà d'autres aux petits conseils car
glaunec du couches de vêtements et des
chaussettes sec on va bien suivre les
conseils du boss ah ouais je pense qu'il
faut bien l'écouter parce que c'est des
choses qui le il connaît bien alors
c'est l'un de vos quatre parrains ya
donc maicon cet aventurier explorateurs
et à delvin lannuzel qui est
scientifique chercheuse qui est
spécialiste de l'antarctique il ya
également une autre navigatrice quand je
dis une autre parce que je faisais
référence à tirer du bois ces cas risque
renner voilà qui
une partie cycle on gagne et on en est
loin mais qui a réalisé la meilleure
performance féminine sur le vendée globe
depuis qu'il existe et puis un quatrième
parent aussi qui est très heureux de
vous accueillir dans son atelier donc
c'est sympa ces petits mots de mike horn
allez un autre un autre objet c'est à
qui le tour l'abattant l'anah je pense
que j'ai quelqu'un qui me fait de l'oeil
là bas je crois oui il faut il faut oser
je rappelle que les manches on ne trouve
que dans l'hémisphère sud et c'est
l'objet donc de thônes études comme tu
l'as dit c'est un manchot oui et ce
n'est pas un pingouin voilà c'est vrai
que beaucoup de gens encore aujourd'hui
confondent manchots et pingouins les
pingouins c'est dans l'hémisphère nord
ok en génération des oiseaux qui volent
tandis que les manchots c'est dans
l'hémisphère sud ils sont meilleurs
nageurs que volatile exactement y nagent
très bien et d'ailleurs tant mieux
puisque c'est là où il pèche c'est leur
moyen de survie et qu'est ce que tu as
étudié précisément sur sur ces manchots
qu'est ce qui t'intéresse moi je vais
particulièrement me focaliser sur
comment ces manchots se répartissent
l'espace de nidification j'ai vraiment
envie de comprendre comment un espace
est plutôt occupé par telle espèce ou
telle espèce dans un même environnement
et voir comment les changements à venir
pourraient modifier ses relations entre
les espèces c'est à dire que moi j'ai vu
quelque chose qui m'intéresse là-haut
veulent sortir
c'est un drône c'est un drône donc par
l'emploi de drones je vais pouvoir
survoler les colonies et voir la
topographie et le type de sol qu'ils
occupent allez prochain objet nils alors
je vais choisir le baromètre qui l'a
donc nil situe à récupérer le baromètre
c'est tout à fait logique puisque toi tu
bosses sur le climat et notamment sur
l'évolution de la couche de neige sur le
continent antarctique en fait ce qu'on
appelle le bilan de masse de surface
c'est l' équilibre entre tous qui arrive
sur l'antarctique sous forme de neige ou
de pluie et tout ce qu'ils font est en
fait moi je vais étudier un processus
qui contribue largement à perturber cet
équilibre est donc c'est mais rivière
atmosphérique que c'est un terme que
j'ai rarement entendu je pense que le
public est un peu comme moi qu'est-ce
qu'une rivière atmosphérique une rivière
atmosphérique c'est qu'une image qui
désigne un courant aérien une sorte de
chenal atmosphérique qui transportent de
l'humidité et de la chaleur est pour
former une rivière il faut deux
formations il faut déjà un anticyclone
donc c'est ce qu'on entend à la météo
s'est associé au beau temps une zone de
haute pression et il faut une dépression
donc ce qui est souvent associé à du
mauvais temps si la dépression vient
heurter cet anticyclone les deux
formations dont je parle ont des sens de
rotation différentes et en fait entre
ces deux formations on va avoir eu un
phénomène de rivières comme une sorte de
tapis roulant d'humidité qui va être
projeté vers l'antarctique et est ce que
ça veut dire que les changements
climatiques qui s'opèrent en ce moment
pourrait avoir une incidence sur ses
rivières atmosphérique en fait c'est
vraiment l'objet de mon étude c'est de
voir comment dans le contexte actuel
quelle évolution on a sur l'intensité
des rivières et sur leur fréquence ce
qui impacte largement donc le le bilan
de masse de surface de l'antarctique est
apte et ça peut en fait contribué à
déstabiliser ce qu'on appelle des
plateformes glaciaires et ensuite à
terme ça peut contribuer augmenter le
vêlage des icebergs et donc à augmenter
le niveau le niveau des eaux ce qu'il
faut bien comprendre c'est que le
continent antarctique c'est vrai que on
a du mal à s'en faire une image je crois
qu'en moyenne ces 1600 mètres de deux
classes sus de la roche oui c'est ça et
ça peut aller jusqu'à 3000 4000 mètres
d'épaisseur au niveau du centre de
l'antarctique en fait 70% de l'eau douce
présentes sur terre est au niveau de
l'antarctique pour avoir un ordre de
grandeur du volume de glace que ça
représente si jamais l'antarctique
venait à fondre intégralement ça
représenterait une élévation du niveau
moyen des océans de 57 m je vais
continuer du coup dans les projets
scientifiques alors qu'est-ce qu'il vous
évoque c'est des petites particules de
plastique et ça représente pas mal le
projet d'olivier qui consiste à étudier
les micro plastiques donc communément ce
qu'on appelle microplastiques ces
petites particules de plastique
inférieure à 5 mm et olivier va les
étudier d'une part dans l'eau pendant
toute la traversée de l'atlantique et
dans l'océan austral mais aussi dans la
neige et dans les sédiments autour des
colonies alors ça c'est pour les micro
plastiques il y à un autre élément qui
va être étudiée c'est le phytoplancton
exactement et ça c'est le projet de
baptiste et de clément donc satisfait de
la microbiologie et clément de la
biogéochimie
et ça correspond à l'étude en fait des
micro-organismes et de leur présent dans
l'océan donc l'intérêt cette étude c'est
qu'aujourd'hui 25% du co2 émis par
l'homme est absorbée par le par l'océan
pour se développer ces micro organismes
ont besoin d'un élément qu'on appelle
par le léman faire en fait et clément va
regarder dans l'eau justement la
présence ou l'absence de cet élément
faire qui est essentiel au développement
des micro organismes baptiste quant à
lui va regarder
dans les micro organismes
l'adn et la rn des micro-organismes les
gènes en fait qu'ils sont exprimés pour
utiliser cet élément faire aller le
dernier objet c'est une image c'est le
drapeau qui se trouve juste derrière
nous alors c'est le drapeau de la
slovénie et en fait c'est le dernier
pays qui a signé le traité sur
l'antarctique où le traité de washington
a donc été initialement signé en 19 ans
en 1959 en fait l'antarctique c'est un
continent unique pour de nombreuses
raisons mais c'est un continent qui
appartient à personne mais qui est
revendiqué par pas mal de monde donc il
a été découvert en 1819 et depuis il ya
de nombreux pays qui ont participé à son
exploration et donc qui revendiquent des
portions du territoire voilà et puis
c'est l'occasion aussi de dire que ce
continent qu'on a du mal à mesurer quand
on regarde une carte quand on regarde un
globe c'est quand même très très vaste
puisque c'est 14 millions de kilomètres
carrés ouais c'est 1,4 fois l'europe ou
25 pour la france à peu près voilà donc
donc cet immense voilà et c'est immense
territoire et bien aujourd'hui
n'appartient à personne ou plutôt
appartient à tout le monde mais il est
réservé est donc à la recherche à la
science et à la biodiversité ça est en
fait les tous les pays qui font de la
science là bas doivent coopérer dans un
espace assez restreint et ça c'est
l'étude de margaux donc qui est
sociologue et qui va travailler sur la
collaboration entre les différents pays
présents sur zone et donc en fait on a
plusieurs corps de métiers qui
interagissent et qui coopère ou pas sur
ce territoire et c'est l'objet d'études
de maroua merci l'anah merci nils on va
vous laisser
achever votre préparation d'ici quelques
jours vous allez levez l'ancré puis pour
tous ceux qui veulent vous suivre durant
votre périple et bien c'est possible sur
les réseaux sociaux et puis via votre
site internet oui c'est ça le site c'est
jdd pour l'association juste 2° j2 des
points d'orgue et on est sur tous les
réseaux donc facebook instagram twitter
et linkedin voilà et bien bon vent bonne
collecte d'informations pensez à bien
vous couvrir et puis
va évidemment vous demanderez de vos
nouvelles durant votre périple et puis
j'espère bien vous accueillir ici au
même endroit ici quelques mois votre
retour pour que vous nous racontiez
comment ça s'est passé voilà à très
bientôt et bon vent merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]